a judge in st. Louis could decide at any
time whether Missouri's only abortion
clinic can stay open Missouri is one of
several states now facing a backlash
over controversial abortion limits CTM
investigative correspondent Anna Werner
is here and what's at stake in Missouri
and also these other states
well Tony at least five other states are
at least one closure away from having
zero clinics now many states are
beginning to pave a path to challenge
roe v-- wade under a conservative
leaning Supreme Court but some states
with so-called hurt beat bans are seeing
the costs of passing those laws abortion
rights supporters rallied outside of st.
Louis courthouse yesterday in a fight to
keep the doors to Missouri's only
abortion clinic open they're gonna have
a fight on their hands like they've
never seen before a judge inside heard
arguments over Planned Parenthood's
request for a temporary restraining
order that would stop the state from
refusing to renew its license shame on
Missouri politicians in Missouri
government for weaponizing the licensing
and regulatory process to end safe and
legal abortion in Missouri the Missouri
Department of Health says it's a safety
issue over violations of state laws and
regulations the department director left
the door open to negotiate if we could
talk with the doctors between now and
then and reach a resolution as to those
issues that we have concerns about and
it might be a simple saying yes we all
wish that hadn't happened but this is
what we're gonna do in the future to
keep it from happening and we would say
fine Missouri is one of six states to
approve legislation banning abortion
within the first eight weeks of
pregnancy
Georgia faces potential losses of more
than two billion dollars over it
TV shows and movies including Avengers
are filmed there and entertainment
companies like Disney Warner Media NBC
Universal and CBS Corporation have
joined Netflix in saying they may stop
production there if the law goes into
effect pulling more than 92,000 movie
and television jobs from the state well
none of the laws passed have taken
effect yet so abortion is still
available in all 50 states if the judge
denies Planned Parenthood's restraining
order and its license expires it will
have the option to file an appeal
something the organization says it will
consider think about the women though
that they may have appointments for
tomorrow
yes Sunday or Monday what do they do yep
all right a lot of uncertainty there
sure it's a scary time for a lot of
people thank you very much Anna